يوم غضب جديد نظمه الاكراد في باريس بعد
هجوم يوم الجمعه لكن الاشتياق لم يتحول
الى فوضى على غرار تظاهره يوم السبت فغابت
الشعارات السياسيه ضد تركيا واعلام العمال
الكردستاني لكن شيئا وحيدا لم يتغير هو
مطالبه المتظاهرين السلطات الفرنسيه
بالاقرار بالطبيعه السياسيه للهجوم وخصوصا
ان المتهم بالاعتداء يواجه تهمتي القتل
ومحاوله القتل على اساس عنصري وفق مصدر
قضائي فرنسي كشف ايضا ان المشتبه به
بالاعتداء الدامي سائق قطار متقاعد يحمل
جنسيه الفرنسيه واقر باعترافات صادمه
بينها رغبته بقتل عدد اكبر اضافه الى انه
يكن كراهيه مرضيه للاجانب
في المركز الديمقراطي الكردي الذي اتهمه
اردوغان وحشيته بانه مركز غير قانوني
لمنظمه غير قانونيه وده في تخين ليه قاعد
جنبك
المجلس الديمقراطي والكردي عزاء اسباب
الهجوم الى تقصير امني فرنسي في حمايه
اماكن كورديه حساسه تقول بيرفين السيد
الكرديه الاشهر في فرنسا اليوم ان ذلك لم
يتغير برغم الاعتداء الدامي
لكن على اي حال نحن نتلقى التهديدات عبر
البريد الالكتروني والرسائل النصيه
هواتف
ليس تقليلا من هول المصيبه بل لافتقادها
عناصر وادله تنفي فرنسا حتى الان وجود
ارتباطات لمنفذ العمليه مع السلطات
التركيه محاوله ربما لعدم صب الزيت على
علاقات متعثره لا ترغب باريس بزياده نارها
مع انقره التي استدعت السفيره الفرنسيه
احتجاجا على ما اسمىته بالدعايه السوداء
ضد تركيا يوم الاحتجاجيه جديد الاكراد
انتهى في باريس لكن احتمال تجدد لتظاهرات
ما يزال قائما وهو بانتظار ما ستؤول اليه
التحقيقات فادي دهوك العربيه باريس